let's go I'm fired the [ __ ] up might as
well go baby
alright man it's the big red Slugger and
big red rocket
what's up Ryder it's the fighter in the
Ferrari today oh I'm not mad at that you
had a fight on a Ferrari for Ron don't
because the kid the kid apparently his
show got good ratings he's been mi a o
Shah with the show not not me bro now
Bryan's been shooting every day canceled
every day so far since the show every
single day every day who's knocking at
who is it knock knock knocking at that
door that's not Brian that's life that's
why deeper Browns a weave that's a wig
bro it's a weird tight-ass sweats like
that retouching girls here what's up bro
yeah did you take them off them yeah you
don't do that what's up bro my state
yeah yeah man it's a mug from Peoria
down south
yeah that's dangerous territory down
there good people if you like good be
south side bro no yeah no that's outside
of Chicago this is down south see the
map Brennan has a map at home it looks
like this okay says America written on
it under it [ __ ] giant get out states
there's a ship it's the only guy not
much man just sitting in here kicking it
it's for [ __ ] freezin here we're just
[ __ ] on Callan how easy you guys are
doing a show together now and and that's
gonna take up the majority of the
Internet's time because that's what
people want to see is you - I think it
should just be me and here by myself you
two are doing a show this guy's not even
[ __ ] here anymore I just be me
sitting in this thing by myself with
chin and catches he wouldn't be a bad
ghost of
when you know he's a great car you have
the property the producer of Rome gets
jealous rook of the year can't get here
Lee Jung the chassis that continuing the
belt you like that what was that movie
where the kid had the fucked-up arm
played for the Cubs and toss it out it's
recent ads rookie Jim Abbott monkey but
loving oh he had one arm bra yeah
Torres roto this kid was tore it off bow
for a clean off yeah yeah tug of war
accident yeah I haven't do one of the 60
or 70 probably best one-armed people of
all what's up yeah Callen gets jealous
bro yeah he texted me both you I'd watch
him said that he said I'm really tired
of you guys taken over my show it's my
show and I said it's not your show it's
it's all of our show it's a community
show yeah the fighter and the kids it's
called although the own I talked about
that on his show you guys got a written
the kid kid is a weird thing to say on
who now anyway you talent in this client
in this guy know and you know what I
kill rivals
I don't brought up animals yeah and
there's you know kids choose just on the
table
no it's creepy for sure we have kids
toys up there I get it creepy here's the
thing though
I told Brian when I first met him he was
hey I'm Brian the kid can you excuse me
who gives you that name is that's just
what they call me you know that's cool
then we got to know each other dude the
name kid doesn't make sense cuz you're
old as [ __ ] he goes I know onset I saw a
movie one time that he referred to
Robert De Niro sona's the kid so he just
took it Robert Redford you know Callens
from cows the same age as Robert Redford
yeah the same age same generation really
yeah yeah he called him Robbie they knew
that he knew Bob is Robbie Robbie bio it
kallen just took nicknamed himself I
don't wait you know but we know Brian
well enough to know nobody calls him the
kid I've never heard of no one's ever
called him the kid never someone called
him that I'm sure probably I've heard
people say be a hell people call him
Papa yeah somebody call him Papa so I
got him he's my FaceTime the other day
with a couple of kids they called him
dad that make sense how many kids do you
think he has seven no three yeah three
total how many does he have on the books
17 no it's not
he's a Philip he's a Philip Rivers of
this podcast what are you laughs like a
[ __ ] haunted
yeah dude maybe you should get an
exorcism I've left like a bug yeah one
of these guys always they're like maybe
you should get a exorcism they always do
that because it means something it comes
[ __ ] what do you live what kind of
Devils do you think are trapped inside a
shop oh all work at a skateboard shop I
told ya say he looks like a [ __ ] he
looks like his dad owns a [ __ ] gas
station he dresses like every dude whose
dad owns a gas station porkchops
actually pretty funny I could see him
doing griptape by the beach sure shop
job job job how's that not a job job
it's a job job yeah we're gonna be
grouped - and [ __ ] ripping ways mean
yes and they're just talking [ __ ] we're
doing the show he's just sitting there I
just sit there doing the job you have to
commentate it
it's like [ __ ] shark tank yeah job
jobs yo if you never fought what would
you have done for real like what would
have been yeah dude you would have
probably had to get a job with FedEx you
think FedEx what can Brown do for you
yeah you're in the warehouse oh yeah
better yet do what the [ __ ] would you do
with your skillset if you were in a
comic what in the world would you do you
got a bevy of skills though he really
does yeah urban planner I graduated
college or urban planner didn't graduate
college you were homeschooled
he built exactly st. Louis that was his
design that entire set - do you wanna
get hired as the bird at Red Robin with
that couldn't be around kids just might
say I would have got a sex change I'm
gonna lesbian I found some hot chick to
[ __ ] take care of me yeah that's
actually very legit if you are no [ __ ]
if you're a young guy and you were like
things aren't going for you so well
somewhere get 10 grand get a crock get a
real [ __ ] and just get tits is that all
the cost to get don't get it yeah it is
tits are so easy that's
you put sand in a man's chest and it
feels like tis no - do you guys looking
this wrong you get tits you suck the
dude off for a year or so get paid and
then get married right and then you just
get rid of the tits that's such a long
plan I'm off for a couple years you have
a big deal get rid of it what do so much
more sell your stupid [ __ ] plan dude
it sounds like inception wrap travel
into the past
leave your dick to a 3d printer have it
printed out take a space shuttle no what
would you have done if you were in a
comic oh I'd be working construction
blue-collar job nothing nothing that's
wrong with it but that's literally what
I would've done when you definitely got
in trouble for a domestic dispute summer
days yeah like you'd be a bad teammate
yeah I want to come home hard day you
know where's my Stu
there's no Stu I'm man my 15 little
redheaded kids are running around hit
your wife yeah dad I wouldn't hit her
but I would you'd be tough to let her
know yeah I would let her know here's
what you can do instead of hitting
somebody you can set there you can just
put your hand make your hand really hard
and just touch it against the side of
their head for a sec yeah that's fair is
it you feel like you'd be like the
warden off Shawshank Redemption that's
the vibe I jump sometimes people on the
internet say I look like Boggs from
Shawshank Redemption the redheaded guy
that made him bring up the lady boys
yeah Boggs look at that that's me some
people someone goes that's Santino you
and Kevin Spacey into one person that's
a five [ __ ] Kevin Spacey very little
isn't it dude if he goes Kevin Spacey
now now I'm gonna give you something to
swallow oh he's just walking and that's
when he's like I take this ice pick well
was it calm semen yep oh wow yeah
without a doubt
because then I'll show you what's fully
going on I thought maybe you put a
little bit of like had a little bit of
you know some chocolates that is 100% me
in 15 years there I am and the hooks
Morgan Freeman say he's like sometimes
wish I could wake you so I know you're
sometimes
and e1 other times hate to say he didn't
win and II had to take some dick here we
go the [ __ ] out of him in there in that
movie theater [ __ ] out of me the [ __ ]
out yeah but then but then Andy had Andy
had the guards whoop his ass and they
made it so he drank to her straw for the
rest of his life that's what I said but
not all of them the homies that suppose
in his ass yeah well the lowdown hear
all that yeah he's in bro I wasn't in
prison yet this isn't I'll here I'll do
my how long were you last in prison
Denis three days with that haircut you'd
have to shave your head
I wouldn't shave my head my head looks
bad she's gonna shower like john c
reilly with a shaved head if you could
shave his hair off is that the oh
there's some we're actually kinda that
is kind of like a little mustache goatee
on him real fast what is it called that
you have a little freaking what's that
called goatee it's not a goatee goatee
would be the full [ __ ] that's a goat
again homeschool I don't have that [ __ ]
dude I got that bottom goatee isn't it
called the soul patch no bad yeah you
got that
that's that redneck that ballers uh half
a [ __ ] yeah do you got a half
mortgage on Syria I thought eBay that
that that it up or on a hundred pounds
I'll be john c reilly well 50 are you
doing yoga again what are you doing like
yeah yeah you're looking good you good
thanks man you look like you're ear like
getting getting back in the good mental
and physical space huh
yeah I've been feeling pretty good man
what are you waiting huh what do you
weigh anywhere from a buck seventy to a
buck probably 90
what do you weigh around the holidays
you get up to 190 2006 two to six what
are you I'm about 246 yeah you're gonna
lose it every carnival if you [ __ ] 226
what are you yeah dude why don't I have
two 194 common core 95 nine bro I don't
know I didn't know I didn't know if it
was more muscle or fat lately 190 I bro
what do you think I am what people that
are 195 look like what am i what I'm not
am i 195 what do I look like one a look
180 Oh what's the exchange rate though
on you guys wait wait holidays anyway I
weigh probably 178 I'm 6 1 I weighed 195
you're not 6 1 bro
no one is 195 yes no heavy you have a
steel hip I got heavy legs do you mean
what do you like right here
don't weight it down he won't get
natural it is pretty heavy 30 knots -
how much does they'll he away cuz he's
about my height if not taller
he's 160 116 but he works on these ads
at 16 what's on fake pads do people need
to know that cristela no does that no he
puts on fake pet weight pads to look
bigger okay and he has an airbrush guy
come over to his house and airbrush so
it looks like muscle lines yeah it's the
saddest [ __ ] even is the dog somebody
brings a dog's dad dude and you know how
that you know how the movie sets have
fake fronts to their house and then you
go inside and there's nothing look at
that those are borrowed dogs rentals
yeah he's got to give those back up at
1:00 in the morning he has to wake up
I want to him just to get note she does
probably he dressed somebody said that
he drinks his openers blood that got
Michael a note you would know she's
blood yeah just a young Berlin command
they don't show a lot of pictures all
the nurture from the waist down guys
huge legs outdoors legs way outdoors
like [ __ ] dead [ __ ] how much do you
weigh how much you think I know how much
I told you right
how tall you six two ish six three okay
so your to know he's who 26 to 18 no
he's 204 to 27 he's the closest to old
phanty knows the closest yeah
- OH - yeah I guess - OH - first did you
I didn't change it I think I love - yeah
because you can't ask you it's wait is
that right first of all I don't really
give a [ __ ] but oh boy she answers I'd
wake and women are impossible to guess
their way down I say 97 pounds
I don't know women's weight I have no
idea she's so offended look at how Maj
here I weigh 130 pounds
oh wow that's healthy 97 what are you
talking about I don't know
I don't know dogs wait I don't know what
logs me bro idea I told you about his
map dude yeah I drew a mountain in the
middle of the country what mountain
range is out there you think how many
states are in the united states of the
same map feels mom drew him dude women's
weights [ __ ] impossible together idea
I don't think it matters what women
weigh I think it matters how I feel
you're a [ __ ] I do expect that with
those sweats on but here's the thing I'm
telling you little twinks that are back
at home you're not getting a girl or
whatever if you want to change your life
save up 10 grand
get a little Siraj installed all eights
bro but here go saying get that end
grant it costs way more than 10 grand to
get gender reassignment oh it doesn't
weigh more Chen look that I've been
watching away mexica do it's way more in
Mexico to go to Mexico that's definitely
where you don't want to go to get your
dick cut off no you can get a dick for a
nose instead if you wanna bleep you
idiot they don't just say you don't when
you wake up in a bathtub with your like
organs missing yeah your dick 1 what
does it take the other ones do it
averages they need all those jobs
a hundred grand hundred see Randy seeds
okay you ever some jazz on TLC alone
a typical genital plasti alone so 18,000
is what you looking at that for nose job
you [ __ ] Janet Oh plastic you think
what is on your nose huh Brett says
rhinoplasty is mrs. rhino
that's 4314 typical genital plasti costs
18 grand genital Plast is not a sex
change in it toe plasti by the way
there's always an upcharge that's like
that's like when you go to the nuts is
extra how much for the nose got any more
well that's just taking like that's like
making more hands and it costs more than
what you leave with it in like a it's
like when you get an urn when someone
dies I do you want them in a nice urn
and a glass one or a box I'm sure when
you're doing things it's way more than
18 to start you guys are not 18 deny
ffice I'll say this ours cost 17 grand
male-to-female yeah great we just saved
a thousand dollars
better this conversation another ten
minutes to discuss won't be a 10-gram
where i want to be at what I'm telling
you freakin animals is this dude how
much your tits no chin to my point tits
are almost free bro you could [ __ ]
get at it anywhere there's one they give
them away now yeah there's a guy down in
Venice Boardwalk that does it if you
watch his YouTube video you guys a fan
of fake titties bitchin dude dude you
know why when your girl hasn't that's
why you love them no hold on I yes I've
always loved them no first of all I
think I would do one on one off because
yeah sometimes you won't want something
you don't like this is the left side
grab the bottom so you can rotate them
to the back with real ones like real
ones you wrote a lazy his wife seems
lazy susan
but i want to say this though is that so
listen your little fellows if you need
you're a young guy maybe your bones to
having developed that strong or
something and you need to get out you
you know things aren't going well at
home for 20 grand or now it's 17 grand
you can get a gender reassignment you
can get a vagina you come out here dude
sell that young ass to some [ __ ] rich
boys out here you can be making 10k
massive vagina you mean sell that young
vajayjay not ass is still there you got
the ass no but why wouldn't you sell the
vagina I wouldn't sell my ass hey I know
something
don't let a double bromine you just said
you would humble blow realize you're one
here
you're a terrible businessman you get
the sex change than you selling your ass
all that work and you did or use that
you go the whole time and you would chop
off your [ __ ] and then you'd suck a
bunch of guys off you said you're gonna
blow first of all you're not gonna give
up your ass or your new [ __ ] you
despise always about them gay sex in
here [ __ ] have a sex change then give
up your [ __ ]
oh man I'm saving a vagina for [ __ ]
married you
not everybody's I wonder if you're given
their [ __ ] away to somebody you would
be such a [ __ ] as a transgender Theo
you just know I would muck and sweet the
library I would be taking care of myself
I would be different well what job would
you have where would you work huh where
would you hard work for the city dude
yeah
toll booth a lot of TJ's in disease I
could see you doing uh I could see you
doing the the meter maid I could see you
doing that rippin tickets Oh a lot of
teachers oh yeah dude I thought it was
trans gingers when I first heard I
nobody did the redheads I [ __ ] saw
them bro I was like they've been through
enough
well no we all are allowed to get free
shoes before you get this on sex change
you need to educate yourself on the
government this favorite book is the
movie of mice and men okay all of you
guys get a job in teaching the teachers
are on strike both of you guys feel
could be teaching your [ __ ]
seven-year-old right now about
transgender sit down guys did you just
talk regular i'ma do my same my natural
voice if I'm trans dad that's a turn-off
if you did yeah let me hear your
transgender voice all right hey guys I'm
Robin and I'm your guide for today so
I'm gonna dim the lights a little bit
because my [ __ ] blood starts to boil
because I've had so many bad pills and
in my body so I'm gonna go take a nap
you guys teach yourselves you figure it
out yeah that's a guide well then what
were you where were you showing but what
was the guide for well I was this
teacher I'm a study I must teach
students I'm a study hall I'm here your
voice if you got transgender surgery see
I would go opposite I'd get a deep voice
kind of everybody it's Gina here you'd
be a Gina it's Gina hair night
geology iago opposite because I feel
like it's it's [ __ ] up and just to go
opposite and you didn't do that
of course he's gonna go with the female
voice I feel like that's too on the nose
ran his head Jeana and I think they
ought to think of any he-hey there's no
his brain does like geology and
genealogy yeah just the most obvious the
female voice hey guys this is Robin no
I'm teaching hey guys this is Rob you
I'm game [ __ ]
what would you do Santino I'd stick with
the same voice I wouldn't tell Holly I
did it
it'd be me with them with the beer I go
hey guys it's me and you play for the
Bears oh yeah oh yeah Jimmy J color if
you got a sex change
everybody would understood his stats I
guess sorry man I'm a huge too risky fan
I never liked Jay Cutler well why is Jay
killer did so much [ __ ] hate man his
attitude he look he's a rich kid he's a
rich girl who played girl who plays that
bad he's a Christian Laettner oh [ __ ] in
the NFL no not as much Christian
Laettner of the NFL would probably be
somebody like it's got to be somebody
that was kind of like his lad boy a
little bit that's true yeah he was good
in Denver
color was really good and as much better
in Denver than he was in Chicago he's
just a wild card right there you know he
has a show on you about with his girl
Kristin Cavallari from marry the girl
friend eee show yeah kicked his coverage
too but i'd have nice eyes so here's the
thing about the airline tube on that
show he's the star hazy
yeah because right no people love him
cuz he's funny
yeah on the show he's funny oh why he's
it yeah me too I thought he was a
complete morons acute it you watch the
show and you like got [ __ ] he's actually
pretty cool I don't like that picture of
him right there though but otherwise
he's a cute here's the thing pictures of
them together or I can't even [ __ ]
see that dude his wife is fine dude you
would you got a chub huh no sweats you
know job I'm not getting an erection in
the [ __ ] pants my grandfather died in
oh [ __ ] you look warm
yeah J colored that that show actually
helped that most people were making fun
of he didn't want to do it yeah and then
the one the few times they showed him
fans loved him cuz he's funny and then
they're featured and more and more yeah
well I get that you don't I mean he's
got a I think a lot of these guys want
to get in a reality TV now that's like a
big thing with NFL dude I want to be
humping her well look at that look at
how young can't go back to pictures look
how young Cutler looks there that's
insane
that's why do you think Jay Keller just
stays off social media conspiracy mean
to him
how do I feel so mean to that guy people
show me to everybody on social [ __ ]
media yeah but Jake you're the territory
of winning in life a more famous and
popular anybody gets especially when
you've a beautiful wife they're gonna
[ __ ] on you yeah they just want to it's
like people want to do that what movie
premiere is at at that they keep [ __ ]
showing shoo-in every second counts
unless it's sharknado Seth with Jay
Cutler all never acted like he cared
that's what I felt like
but there was a lot of guys like that in
the NFL that come and they go and they
don't really give a [ __ ] cuz they got
their money he got sometimes these guys
know they're not gonna be a superstar so
they're like whatever dude lot so he
gets paid he's like [ __ ] this man like
they get jaded he's like alright [ __ ]
this this sucks
yeah they have their money uh Jay Cutler
celebrate what did that say Jen their
third wedding anniversary I love them
more and more every day this imposter
can't believe when do you run out of LA
who's I gotta go guys and I love you
dude I do you know how you want to do
your show right now is it really January
what dude stay transgender Road State
transgender bro you jealous fool the
[ __ ] out of me I didn't know bro keep
doing that yoga so you lose the tits out
the front a week a day let me see pull
up the back of your shirt so yeah here I
go alright you get that ass of Jay
Cutler both you guys look really not
good okay thank you really
very good what soon it gives up at the
bottom do it's a little flat bro it's
kind of flat it looks like that's not
bad
bro it's a game it's like it wants a
drink and you'll never get an invitation
by whatever louis c.k look like louis
ck's nah easy Joe easy Joe
too easy easy easy and shitty joke
you're better than that feel good no
it's not yeah no it's not
yeah cuz you rather green if you had a
motorbike that's not what a compliment
what a compliment you just gave me later
brother
dude I spoke very highly of you take it
easy cousin oh really
yeah he's a sweet kid he's a good one
he's a sweet kid
but you know I get concerned about him
do you yeah his mental health huh me too
something's missing Oh in a big way like
a couple of chromosomes oh yeah I get so
nervous about that guy walking the
streets I get nervous about him he he's
either go to directions he didn't go the
Heath Ledger or Steve Jobs you know
there's no middle with him he's gonna be
like what's a name McAfee that lived off
on that Island and it did weird [ __ ]
like made girls poop on them and then be
friend of the cops and bought him all
guns that's gonna be Theo or else you
know what he's gonna do he's gonna be
the guy who gets super religious and
tries going to that Satan Island tries
to give them [ __ ] Bibles and [ __ ] oh
yeah I might do that [ __ ] Ashley it
sounds like a good time I think when you
get rich you find religion again because
you get so rich that you got to believe
in something but here's the thing you
want to outdo all the other billionaires
so [ __ ] climbing Everest you want to go
that Satan Island see what's up bro oh
yeah no one survived it yeah that's true
and take pictures with your cell phone
and stuff and like having fun with him
in drinks see if you can get in and get
out yeah maybe but then also it's kind
of like well that has to be the end of
your life I can do that [ __ ] when I'm
like 80 you can't you're not fast enough
any if you train for it at 80 if you
train your whole life take steroids
yeah yeah I'm gonna start taking
steroids in my late 60s you can't wait
to you're 60 yeah because I just feel
like then I don't care if I die I feel
like you have a lot of energy I do have
a ton of energy yeah so I mean that's
right like now I'll be good so a 60 I'll
slow down steroids and I'm good
steroids and I'm back and I'm like right
back to it I know I have too much
[ __ ] energy these fans think I'm on
drugs
people said Santino is on something no I
feel like most people think Thomas
comics are on some drugs
well like D'Elia people think D'Elia is
always on [ __ ] he's the most sober
person I know he's actually never had
he's never you doesn't do drugs look at
that good what did that say getting oh
it's better to take drugs than you got
older see look at that
yeah get older just put on hold for a
while that's right [ __ ] do this
that's gonna be me
I don't know here's some big-ass hands
want to be award-winning jacked when I'm
90 I can't believe Callen has
non-steroid day he's so obsessed with
the male body and the big dudes I just
can't believe he hasn't done it yet is
he still doing that thing where he's
buying guys online to come over just to
stare at him for a long time yeah I'm
still doing it you know right now yes
muddies is he's paying for multiple one
look at that dude that's gonna be me
that's Santino you hopefully not would
that live here what happened was fun no
play out a stroke then got on steroid if
he's dry that's like if he dropped a
weight on his face who's I still getting
chair I'll [ __ ] work for this workout
dude [ __ ] yeah he looks good you know
what people at the gym I don't go to
gyms anymore dolma why you rats me dude
wow that guy's jaw Santa Jackie has acne
on his abs damn it those aren't abs so
that's when it looks really weird it
looks like like play-doh bulges these
are not a human growth hormone so it
makes all your organs grow too so you
get like that power gut I know but that
vein is so tight that bicep vein is
hilarious sexy bro yeah so much blood
probably can't you don't like that come
on that's hot I'm les here for you the
veins is what creeps me out
I don't like you so you're gonna like
veins some of them yeah
no mine looks a roadmap I'm out yeah do
you have pain you have a lot of weight
yeah oh yeah like a tree badge
you think veins are gross uh not
necessarily gross when they pop out a
little too much like they look like
they're gonna burst yeah like that
- pop yep I just got his pump on same
thing with like skinny dudes who have
their veins popping out that bothers me
- sometimes you can see a couple dicks
with a strong root vein in it I don't
know how are you a veiny guy no Maya I
have a vein you can see pretty clear
when I'm human I have one it's not thick
it's kind of a skinny kind of I have one
vein on my dick
and it and it candy canes around my
penis all the way around Wow they're
like a barbershop sign that's my car you
know what I just realized we Theo
brought up all this trans stuff I know
I'm gonna get so much [ __ ] because Theo
ran is more about nice time then she'll
come in talk about trading genders and
then he made it sound like he made it
negative for all the fans at home I
didn't know anything negative about the
trans community I want to put that out
there cuz I [ __ ] I don't like getting
roped into [ __ ] when it sounds like I
said something bad when it was steel and
you know what I give him the sphere of
thought let's not talk about dicks today
Brandon can you do that and pass my new
year's resolution and feel just brings
out of me he started it I know he
started all that talk dude let's change
this up how's your podcast going how's
the whiskey whiskey ginger is good
whiskey ginger is good we we just added
a whole you revamped everything huh yeah
well we're well I'm shifting Studios now
too because I'm gonna be up at Tom
Seguros place cuz you what are we at
your mom's house well not my mom I'm
gonna be mom's house oh cool man well
she lives in Aurora so I'm already been
I'm already there right now oh well
mentally I'm there okay
basically I'm here I've been walking
around in this body but I left my mind
with your mom a long time ago I gotta
tell you bro he is a genius he's smart
she's sweet she's sexy okay she can cook
gotta tell you she can cook maybe she'd
never cook for you so you the girl you
were so girl launched the network yes I
go ahead yeah well kind of it's a it's
like we're doing it at at the studio at
your mom's house to do so it's Matt in
his house though that's no no no we have
it we have his own studio I want to leak
too much info but yeah we got a stop
sign no no I know is he still doing it
out of his old place or no no it's and
everything's at the new studio me Ryan
Sickler they're there Simon Kristina's
and dr. drew oh wow he's like the mini
little network I guess of whatever I'm
surprised Bert's not with him they're
best buds yeah Burt does his own thing
out of his own house and all that [ __ ]
you know I mean Bob Burt
- to do his own studio is he yeah damn
we should have just bought an airplane
hangar all of us and put them in the
same place we should just buy an
airplane hangar at Santa Monica Airport
yeah because all of us gets it in
Rogen's if we want it to but you have so
many moving pieces everyone be in Logans
you have to have your own you need your
own spot like what Showtime did for me
is they built my own stew so I have King
this thing there were Theo and I yeah
then I blow the belt there we're gonna
find the kid their access to it anytime
yeah but no you can do that with an
airplane hangar we could all have access
to that [ __ ] and then you change out
sets you can't do it with Rogan cuz he
needs somewhere to bow hunt inside he
said he needs like 150 yards to [ __ ]
dude you can do an airplane hangar but
you just build like 10 Studios then
having a whole net we're all under the
same network yeah somebody should do it
somebody get on it
you have too many big dogs though
because I'm not gonna percentage of my
shows yeah you want snot doing his show
yeah it's trogon it's like get the [ __ ]
out of my face daliyah's like suck my it
will be under the chin network
you're gonna will you do it for us hell
yeah we're gonna call it chin chin
that's a wrap that already exists - how
the [ __ ] I'm gonna call it chin ups
I'm gonna call chins house whose house
his house that's gonna be it what about
the cheating cat Network [ __ ] cat chat
careful Gingka yeah careful catch you
careful careful careful careful what it
should be called cat catching cats
catching catching catching at work how
about catching cats chin chinny chin and
Kim Kim no I'm a cat goddamn cat well
alright who's more racist Brendan or
Kalin who's more racist that's a good
question you but you both know yeah
they're both racist but who's more
racist cat you had this percentage-wise
who tells the most racist jokes out of
those pounds of [ __ ] get hurt
people's feelings I'm not that should
answer your question right there yes not
recently probably Brendan but internally
probably prior Brian because he grew up
rich yes always ready judges the other
ones rich people are very racist usually
the
both so many rich people are like that
that's not true I'm friends with all the
people that work for me that I've got
our friend yeah see that that's I know
you're right I don't even say of color
when someone's like they're of color
that's lunch strange I when someone said
I think African Americans sounds racist
by the way somebody says that racist we
can you say black fine no any do you
have any but if you would say black
problem any black dude I know would say
you're white I'm black and if I said my
friend my friend mark and if someone
goes is it black guy I wouldn't go who
we go yeah yeah I know I know
no but basically I think cuz it just
comes off racist when someone goes he's
african-american or you know what even
somebody goes he's afro-american oh
jesus [ __ ] christ
that's touchy what do you want
alienation deal with that let me see
African American about Asian American oh
that sounds so standard that American
it's fine
I feel like Asians are the only ones
that can really joke about race anymore
because they're cool about it no that's
not true Mexicans are cool as [ __ ] I
mean me and hater trail we joke he's
good at joking around about asu's is
great he's also comics outside comic
comics are all cool but all people are
weird outside of comics then that's like
anybody gets uncomfortable about
everything you know comics are ya in
this world in if you enjoy comedy and
you're somebody that has like a sense of
[ __ ] humor doesn't take everything
serious yeah you're gonna be fine with
making jokes I think I think like the
average person has to be aware and
almost a on their toes about being
offensive because they're afraid of
losing their job and [ __ ] correct
what has ones last time someone said
something that offended you about being
Asian cat nothing really offends me the
only time is when people think it's like
too buddy-buddy I have friends who'll
joke around call me Ling Ling which is
fine it's just a pro call you what Ling
Li what is that Li Ling Ling like a
generic like stereotypical like Asian
name it was a character from like a
movie yeah exactly like caricature kind
of like generally type of those like a
noodle like a Ling Ling you call Ling
Ling's like Asian oh wait look Louise
lingling a company that exists oh who is
Ling Ling up above that Rosen
what is frozen Asian entrees Wow
so wing wings I call in is that like
calling a Mexican a [ __ ]
no it's not offensive it's just one of
those things where I call them X in a
[ __ ] okay also offensive same thing
yeah yeah both of how many more how many
more can you do just crop me out of the
show no I don't mean I mean Ling Ling is
enjoy our delicious Asian inspired
appetizers and entrees and I tell you
something though the second person that
picture is a white woman obviously a
white person's company that your brand
is look it's an Asian person making the
food it's a white person enjoying it ah
that's what they're selling that keeps
crawling but look at how this is this is
everything about this is falsified white
guys handle delicious that's a white
guy's hand is it not that's a white
man's hand holding it there's also a
barbecue sauce bottom right corner
that's fake dude for sure this is a
white guy who made into a fake Asian
company call it lingo click on his story
let's see his story I'm from Omaha
Nebraska
but I've always loved Asian names oh
look at that it is an Asian family what
are you nerds Clarence my one his name
is what Clarence Clarence he grew up in
San Francisco
Clarence is not an Asian guy's name
there's no way Clarence have you ever
heard of that
ever no you have Iike yes when Asians
come and they have American versions of
their names like they have their
traditional like Chinese or like venom
um but they nobody can renounce it so
they're like oh my name is David I know
but Jaden I've heard Clarence but some
people don't know like normal names like
oh I like the way Clarence sounds so see
I usually heard it on a TV show like
sometimes I've heard that that like a
friend of mine her family was from
Russia and they got em they learned
English from American television and
they named their kids after people from
TV shows oh yeah here all the time
because you'd like I think that's normal
well yeah it sounds like it's it's like
oh that must be what everyone's name is
yeah they're idiot yeah everyone's name
is Gilligan and you're like I got one
guy one show one time let's show one
time this is our child Gilligan that's
our son MacGyver like
let's mag them over there P I so
lingling is race is inherently racist uh
no I think it's just one of those jokes
that I don't appreciate people calling
me if you don't know me I mean it sounds
annoying I call you legally yeah I found
my friends but it's like so they're
coming in tomorrow Mike what's up
lingling yeah yeah but Kat is such a
cool short name already you don't need a
bluesy hat is Kat that isn't my actual
name you gave me that nickname because
you couldn't pronounce my actual name
really how do you not remember that
that's insane that you don't remember
giving her that nickname yeah moving
fast man you're the only person whose
real name is Bartholomew you're the one
who gave me the nickname when they calls
you cat yeah I feel like it what's your
real name
Kat teen ooh I like that a lot that
teens cool but Kat Kat teen cat the cat
team yeah what's up cat I feel like Josh
I'll do this in bed one night at home
he's a cat cat daddy cat daddy cat cat
wait and I was touched on what you feel
cat with the emoji of a cat yeah what's
up cat meow yes I do and which and what
should we call Bartholomew chin Chin's
real name is actually your real name
Joel regard Whittaker heard Beauregard
Frank Jin Jin soo Jin Jin soo Jin soo
Jin Sue's your first Jane I changed it
to chin like she says one we moved to
America my friends couldn't say Jin so
there's a chant chant so I just changed
it to chin chin easy you call me Jim or
chin money Jim because they because they
because they didn't hear you right ya
nah see Jim Jim you got your nothin Jin
they would say okay I am
jaian Jin yeah Jin what's wrong with Jin
the kids didn't say Jin your kids are
seeing it happening right now that just
has like two minutes
Jim Fionn so I called Jin Jing Yi Jin
soo Jim you always say your first and
middle name so mine's just Jin soo Jin
was the last time someone maybe it was
traffic maybe you were at a restaurant
what's the last time someone did
something racist
Lisa's toward you racist
that hurt your feelings or you're like
god I remember a ton when I was younger
but not in a long time what was it when
you were young what was the mo my god
they just point on my face pointer face
I have tiny I just small eyes
they said pen and face that's a tough
one like classic Korean pan face I don't
think I've ever heard that do you have
it
you've heard that I've never heard of
I've heard of that oh yeah my own faith
spared you get us go through the kitchen
cabinet dude I'm telling you where I
come from the skillet head I heard one
kids go [ __ ] off fourth face kids do
just make up mean things to say tit
butter knife I couldn't I heard so many
[ __ ] annoying
fire-crotch Oh peas and a fire crotch
Opie had a pepperoni head because I also
had pimples it was worse it was like a
pimple redheaded kid I mean that's right
says I you know what about big red big
red it's kind of endearing I call myself
red big red the chewing gum though you
know anyone call you hot sauce hot sauce
is cool too I don't mind any that stuff
odd being made me hot sauce hot sauce
hot sauce hot sauce the retards coming
in you know Here Come hot sauce no it
was always older kids that thought it
was funny to make fun of me in front of
chicks no he's always I was actually in
front of dudes
that's because chicks still have
sympathy their whole lives men don't get
sympathy but like girls even they're
young and they see someone being mean to
say I don't like it they're like that's
mean it's not a way to win over no
chicks don't like dudes are [ __ ] to
make other dudes laugh correct the dude
that said yeah exactly it's like the
wacom say we but like if I walk in with
[ __ ] leopard pants on I'm gonna get
gonna get lickin the [ __ ] let's do a we
bond but that's because we're friends
but when people are being like racist
like when someone said that to chin when
somebody said pan face he's trying to
make somebody else laugh by being mean
to him correct and that gordly never cuz
of a girl no never never a girl
Joe would never go oh that guy that
picks on everybody is so cute ooh did
you hear Jeremy called the Asian
Panthers I'm gonna suck I love that guy
never happened not ever bully but that
was it was a fire crotch or or or or
Opie oh it was actually Opie you know
Opie Taylor yeah Ron how
that was actually um he was killing it
that was at me at elementary school that
was always the older black kids would
say that to me but it was it was a term
of endearment so like it didn't hurt my
feelings but it didn't know me yeah you
come hey what's up Oh be here come out
because if older black dudes would
always do that that's really cool I will
stop Opie yeah but they're mocking me
yeah but also you're open but it's cool
that the black guys notice right yeah in
Durban you come to Opie
what is so pan face what else chin
that's not to mean it's not good shabbos
gonna have a made a sound by collection
of every racist thing he said on here on
this episode you know I mean who made
jokes a lot were Mexicans about you yeah
so know about Asians and did a lot act
with the fire because they're Mexican
really did you get a lot of heat from
Mexicans too no I I grew up with a lot
of Mexicans so it's just kind of like
our way of bonding but you but was there
an inherent battle between you two like
in my attention yeah my Frehley Mexicans
and agents Haley others Mexican blacks
Hades ha
agents and Mexicans what crazy so many
sound bites on this episode I'm just
curious
well no I don't rub his back skins and
blacks hated each other no listen my era
though when I was in high school
Mexicans were like at war with the Asian
guys and then but then my best friends
are Mexican - so is just whatever what
would that what else will they call yeah
they're just there's a little song that
they did oh my god yeah they had a whole
song just to hate on Asians and how
would he watch Chino Chino HOPWA nesco
macaque I know me this you never this
ccino ccino ha bonus bonus gourmet caca
coma caca no matter no matter so annoyed
Chinese Chinese Japanese eat my [ __ ] I
don't care yes I'm like that what's not
very creative no it's it's hell yeah
everyone would be my yelling and
screaming that's Terry cause it rhymes
and stuff you know that's awful not like
you of course never ate any of their
[ __ ] never not want your [ __ ] [ __ ]
that narrative it's like I'm making your
turn he's really funny for someone to
say eat my [ __ ] and then say I don't
know
yeah that's how hardcore they were
should have been like eat my [ __ ] please
eat my [ __ ] I'd like to see you do it
yeah but instead you might should I
don't care well if you're indifferent
I'm not gonna eat your [ __ ] don't push
your phony agenda on me that's a weird
agenda I I can't think of anyone in
anyone we hang out with he's legit like
racist towards people there's no but
because they hide it I remember there
was a kid I'm not gonna mention names
but we were in middle school
oh good thing you don't say his name
well dude cuz I don't I'm sure people
watch this stuff from guys went to high
school with too but like um this kid had
said this kid had said to this other
black kid he said he said I know why
you're mad at me because I didn't invite
you to my party and he says he's like no
I don't like your [ __ ] ass anyway and
then the kid said yeah you know I didn't
invite you
cuz I don't want any ends at my mom's
house Oh while he's trying to hurt him
and he punched this kid so [ __ ] I'm
not kidding the black kid punched the
other kids yes dude II hit this kid so
[ __ ] hard in the face I remember
watching it thinking he's dead he killed
him I swear to god he hit him so [ __ ]
hard he fell backwards I was like he
killed him what was he thinking about
what a dumb kid I think he thought he
wouldn't hit him I think he thought he
was jumping up on him cuz he was a
little bit bigger than him I thought I
think he thought he's not gonna [ __ ]
swing at me [ __ ] him
dude his nose opened up like the flood
like that Moses party was like brought
fresh blood everywhere those dead pounds
but he bounced back up it was like in
every branch even the kid that hit him
kind of stood there in awe so we're out
of the playground you couldn't run
anywhere but I remember like everyone
stood there like woah no one I'd ever
seen a punch that solid there cuz he hit
him right on the nose it wasn't a side
it was like his walking straight got six
sixth-grade yeah that's some shoes hit
him so [ __ ] hard I it was over like a
Foursquare remember Foursquare it was
over like a Foursquare game and it all
started from them arguing boys I didn't
fight you my party cuz I don't want to
n-word at my mom's house so wolf and he
shattered his universe yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah bad bad bad that's what you
get dude don't call some of the n-word
you're gonna get knocked the [ __ ] out
show some current events yeah getting
like the [ __ ] out when you're aces yeah
that happens it tends to happen maroon 5
Travis Scott Big Boi
performing the Super Bowl for halftime
show so the lineup for the Super Bowl
halftime show has finally been confirmed
they got Travis Scott and big boy
however Travis Scott made a deal with
the NFL that they had to donate a
certain amount of money to organizations
that promote social justice wow that's
cool because I guess J Zeke right cuz
all the black artists won to protest
against did Big Boi - well a lot of one
contest gets it and jay-z
even went to Travis Scott was like dude
don't perform there the NFL's [ __ ] up
apparently Travis Scott was like kick
rocks camel well here's but here that's
the irony the league is still filled
with black athletes so majority yeah so
to say not to perform is like saying
they're not gonna play like okay well
first of all it's still a business
that's happening so for a black musician
a black artist they should do that just
go word I'll perform you also got to
give money to a thing that I want you to
give money to that's what they're doing
yeah that's that's what I mean like this
is the balance for I get how jay-z is
like yo we have to we should hold up
like our Black Voices and and you know
what I mean like I'd have a standard I
get that but also I get some [ __ ]
money out of the NFL [ __ ] them be like
ya pay me and pay this organization
wrecked but also the NFL employs how
many black people like they're they're
not just the enemy you know like they do
a lot of good as well well yeah the
problem that people have is the width
and NFL handled all that [ __ ] I'm saying
Colin Kaepernick yeah and the wave
thereafter I think people are people
were mad at the way NFL handled it they
all could have hammer people want a moon
five like how can room 5 perform than
howdy really well room 5 maroon 5 wants
donations to L'Oreal hair care products
so he can keep changing his first of all
huge you're a big-time maroon guy love
at him okay sure
and and big boy and try I think he's
fine I don't know like he they don't
miss they have so many jams Nick give me
one right now
wait there's that movie the show wait
singing wait see that's a what about the
song right now wait gonna dinner
minun inin that's a song that I hear in
line at Starbucks and I leave cuz I
don't even feel like getting going to
get your car I'm like that what what
about what about the one with the with
the women where they have all the women
in the video to type in [ __ ] moon
girls like you girls like you give it to
me well how give me give me the - give
me the tune uh I know you know what you
know I know it my smart my son it's his
favorite movie video I'm sorry's music
video girls like you and it has a cardi
B in it we play this [ __ ] Jam
hopefully I'm just gonna say he's gonna
go what it yeah you know this nope I
can't get down with that star boy can't
get down i order more I don't like I'm
dead to you turn this off this is so
terrible dude hold on go to my Instagram
page tell me to like this song when you
see this little girl sing in it
is it your is it your kid no if your kid
is being cute singing I'm gonna like it
that's your little daughter right there
that's that that's my pedophile Fred
yeah that girl sitting on that guy's
head and for real the CTE was such a
funny captions that made me laugh so
[ __ ] hard dude out NFL doesn't have
to worry about helmets worry about these
guys who are getting sat on by these
what about these freaks are getting
[ __ ] like this dude how about the girl
that would that giant ass DME was okay
you need give me credit for that videos
it excuse me how did you did you not
what do you mean didn't you didn't you
tag who get who where you found it or
what do you guys found it barstool yeah
that's a burst you've tried it in the
place you found it correct you're not
gonna go through all the [ __ ] 90
channels of who the queue yeah the
apartment complex is like hey you need
to give us a shout so I think the guy
getting destroyed should be the one
concerned about getting dog look at her
just seven inch Bert son actually for
her weight that's pretty [ __ ]
have you seen the once have you seen the
once where the guys they get farted they
make him fart in their mouth hmm these
girls they fart right in their face no
these dudes love that [ __ ] no way yes
dude that's a big thing on the internet
now
no yeah is that porn I mean what the
difference at this point isn't all the
internet porn everything I look at but I
feel like that guy where is the cute
little girl I want to see her for a
second is it all the way down
it's Wallach all right um is it that far
down I think so you know what I you know
what I really saw that was really cute
as uh the three generations did you see
that well there it is three generation
that's not dude now talk [ __ ] about Adam
Levine after this go ahead said a
biohazard tattoo on that guy's arms yeah
it is bro don't you have a child well
but hey it's very cute dude you know
what it's very cute enough I can't make
fun of this man and his beautiful
daughter because good for them I'm gonna
still make fun of Adam for making a bad
song dude look I'm sure he's a great guy
I don't like that stuff he's so good hey
Adam if you're out there you'll never
ever see this to hear this I bet you're
an awesome dude I bet you're the best
top I don't let you know I don't like
maroon 5 wow I'm sorry it's just not for
me
really who do you like what do you look
at the music you listen
jazzy hacky crash and snap those guys
are great to know them you know Marcus
cooler and the coolers you know those
guys dope the electric light sockets do
you know you know deep inside the
manhole they're good they're out of
Tennessee okay
is that a punk band they're like a punk
[ __ ] band they're like a boyband [ __ ]
punk band they [ __ ] boy bands and then
they write songs about it and punk I'm
into that what do I let you I don't know
you know weird what so it does what do
you listen to I can't tell ya so much
[ __ ] yeah I don't know I listen to
everything what I listen to Clarence
Carter on the way here Clarence Clarence
Carter you know who that is no are you
like yeah I'm 105 yeah dude I like most
of this cigar I like Motown did you
drive in a [ __ ] Clarence
order dude he has such a good song
called too weak to fight too weak to
fight listen to me baby too weak to
fight now how old are you
64 look at that strokin huh Bistro
control kit to the left do you know this
[ __ ] no rise the king hold on
[ __ ] hold on planning the [ __ ] with
Clarence Carter but not Adam Levine
first of all do i [ __ ] with like a dope
dude from Motown yeah do i [ __ ] with
Adam Levine and maroon 5 no I don't
think they own the same category dude
look at that [ __ ] dude look at that
he's not even blind play a song for me
too that's a violin but so that's how
small he is dude what this kind of man
so dope yeah you I hear enough stroking
not this one so well this is okay and
that is a great song but he's a lot of
Hittle down go - uh-oh slip away is such
a good song go up go up go up go up doo
doo slip away dude see from the
Commodores you slip away the second one
the second one the one that says slip
away Jim yeah play this Oh
turn it turn it this makes you want to
rob a bank bro [ __ ]
[Music]
all right I kind of like this you're
like we're the blues brother I feel I
picked you in a Ford Taurus like a 94
Ford Taurus and just jamming out to this
smoking a cigarette headed to Vegas yeah
I wanted to see you right now
[ __ ] yeah and look right here this the
best part though he is good damn dude
it's pretty good what'd he say here
amazing what he's saying slip away he's
talking about a woman who's with another
man and he's jealous and he says can you
slip away just for a moment come on
there's got a [ __ ] huge yes but you
have to love who is - is the first time
I heard yeah there's really good guys
you you would have to appear she
appreciate that era of music like I Love
Boat on my father loves Motown he left
Carolina Beach Music so I love hot [ __ ]
I love this [ __ ] dude like Otis Redding
like Backstreet Boys or train dream to
me you seem like a Death Cab for Cutie
trained no dawg I'm into Motown but do I
like that's new okay here because people
make fun of me that one was [ __ ] good
I'll give you that that was nice I like
dude I stroked him for me I like funk as
solon yeah yeah yeah yeah you like Bruno
Mars he's very good he's so telling he's
so good but I just it's just like a lot
of it's too light or to shoot I'm okay
Taylor Swift guy no dude I can't read
you bro I'm missing here you're missing
by a mile
all right let me look up on some stuff
in here here we go ready here we go
there's a little Lil Wayne a little bit
a little wheezy in here Andrew Bird
Chicago artists never heard of cunning
linguist switch is a hip-hop group uh
what else would you know TV on the radio
I like them yeah yeah but I like mute
Ludovico Einaudi who's a who is a
classical pianist bro I
verse you are I'm diverse dude dude hit
the Beatles Van Morrison ever heard of a
back Big Boy
shout out dude nas I like everything on
if it's good I like it but you don't
like anything new or current it sounds
like you don't like the new [ __ ] I mean
I like new look what I knew what like
pop music like Takashi 6-9 little pump
I don't like washing his six I don't
like guys who do that stuff that he does
with his hair and all that [ __ ] it's too
much he's a grown up dude you're a grown
up cut that cut that [ __ ] childish
[ __ ] out that's fair rainbow bro cut
it out
you a Kanye West fan I I love from I
love music regardless of his political
views I can separate the artist in the
person I know people are so mad about
[ __ ] Kanye in a Maggie had yeah I
[ __ ] I like his music get the [ __ ]
out of here I love a late registration
was a great album so was I mean every
album I love really
I like his old [ __ ] a lot and I like
some of his new [ __ ] to me too
Oh whose new rap that I like um I think
uh Oh Machine Gun Kelly guy no I'm just
off here you're throwing so many [ __ ]
bad
I like often I like I like Pusha T I
thought his album was phenomenal okay
do you know pushing team I dunno pusher
thing uh push her team I'm sure I know
mr. Fogerty I'm familiar with a pusher I
know the push push but I love Motown I
love that era I think funk and soul that
were birthed from like from Motown from
loud you're lucky counts not here right
now he would give you a history lesson
on Motown but I love that [ __ ] I love
that [ __ ] you only people on line said
it I look like Callens kid Oh
people like you're gonna be Callen in
ten years fifteen twenty I go first of
all I'm 35 Callens the inverse plus ten
correct he's 63
I'm never gonna look like that guy okay
ever never I've class and dignity and
sexiness and there's an air to me that
guys and girls sometimes or mostly guys
go those guys kind of a babe I like this
the bass guys kind of a babe no he says
a song for action mmm here we go
yep I'll bet you Clarence
pride cap catcher me too you know what
he's been doing
I'm assume he's not alive right now
Clarence yeah he's not lying I think he
died well you see a lot look at Phoebe's
alive see I was appreciating his talents
until stroke this isn't a good song it's
just funny it's like yeah but it's not a
good song he's got other really good so
let's try again see des 8300 Wow Carter
yeah that's jay-z's dad you know yeah
talent do get out of one family he's
dope where's he from Montgomery Alabama
is that what that says yes yeah it is
people yeah the South has so much great
music like that that came out of it I
mean do you know Sam Cooke you know what
he doesn't mind you'll see what I'm
saying I love that ever sent you like
Sam Sheridan I think that's a father
I don't know do Sam Sheridan yeah is
that right
why don't I say I'm sure did you just
stay at a Sheraton recently and that's
just in your head you might be together
I'm Sam Sheridan Oh who's that let me
see what is an author oh dude come on
yeah he's married to uh Wonder Woman
audiobooks don't count as music no he's
married to Patty Jenkins the director Oh
when he wrote movies Brian's friend and
he's in the gym all the time
oh I liked him too I like Sam Sheridan
sure do you like his music was good done
the same yeah wait oh we always go for
the Super Bowl Super Bowl oh yeah but
anyway room five rules but no do they
need to have three groups no just do one
yeah room five has so many hits just let
them play all three I know you love them
it's just not my [ __ ] I know I their
dough but they don't like them I [ __ ]
celebrate they're good at what they do
fine sure I can appreciate people who
gonna look I don't think I don't like
Taylor Swift stuff I don't put it on but
I know she's good at it yeah what she
does she's gonna I don't I'm saying
that's plenty people that I'm like I'm
not gonna be like [ __ ] maroon 5 the
other night I decided I'm never gonna
put him on I'm never gonna turn that
music on the other night
I took myself a little edible and I
watched [ __ ] an entire concert lot I
think it was live from I was high
live from England and it was Backstreet
Boys and New Kids on the Block and it
was two hours long and you watch it all
of it dude if you need if you need to
hang out with somebody just call me
don't come over I found it so
fascinating that these grown men are
still on tour and they're doing the
dance moves together how fascinated day
would be to find out that this other
grown man is high in an edible watching
their tour and fascinated by Gershwin
I want and I start thinking because I
know how much money like touring Act
made yes well they make them so we break
it down and I wonder how much they make
while yeah I'm gonna get bum I got real
high started looking into it you'd be
surprised but they do a lot of dates you
know big arenas still and the entire
arena all all chicks all chicks see not
me I want all dudes oh my god oh all
dudes
I want all dudes and one girl one girl
one far back do you have a suite I'll
have to clear this past weekend it is
strange I'm like you dumb [ __ ] I don't
you know what you know you know what's
you know what's so funny about [ __ ]
hecklers nobody nobody likes them and
for some reason they still keep popping
the [ __ ] up
like I like trolls on the Internet yeah
it's as if I don't think it's everybody
knows how annoying it is and that's some
reason somebody keeps going I'm gonna do
that to [ __ ] do it
but no one's usually usually that closer
they're never celebrated they're never
sober
no one's ever like ooh you beat that
comic good yeah that's true I've never
seen that work out for him ever yeah but
you know but but I think the thing is
like people also go to comedy shows that
don't really love comedy they just go
cuz it's a night out
yeah and they get drunk yeah yeah and
then they lose themself and they get
into this thing where they're like [ __ ]
we're just having fun man and [ __ ] you
and you're like it's not fun though
you're ruining it for every yeah yeah no
one thinks it's [ __ ] cool but you
know and I'm gonna piss on you from that
I wouldn't heckle you though dudes don't
heckle you
mmm I've had it before in Australia and
st. Louis cuz then you could be like hey
just come up here and we'll fight yeah
that's not funny
the crowd goes yeah but then you go I'm
just kidding ha ha ha but I will fight
you
ah ha ha I will fight you then it's
funny again that's kind of funny what
our next news yeah it's cats what
families who lost their kids from the
Sandy Hook shootings are suing Alex
Jones and they just won a small like
legal battle and they now have the
access to see how much Alex Jones made
from Infowars because they're making the
argument that he's spreading all these
lies in order to make a profit
yeah profiting off lies yeah how much
did you how much do we know no we don't
know they have access to it now I want
to know so bad how much he made that's
such a great that what a great clickbait
piece of article though the Rolling
Stone got us on there too just to not
tell us how much go to the very top
again let me see the picture of Alex
look at him Sandy Hook shooting with
some families we know they won but they
can't disclose it there
they won the ability to look into how
much money he makes from Infowars but
isn't that legal that's that's legal
knowledge right tax filing is legal like
anybody can look up what anybody filed
isn't that true everything I don't think
I don't know I feel like if you operate
a I guess I should correct myself it's
not like the guy that works and I was
right if you run a business and own a
business don't you have to disclose that
public I don't think a bloody trading
company like if you googled net worth
what happens I don't know what I'm
talking about net worth not that I'm a
celeb no but who will mine they say I'm
like I wouldn't really got that like
yeah they compiled it with numbers that
don't mean anything they compiled of net
worth is 10 million
those are say yeah they're estimated to
go up to the top it says 10 million as
they estimate that that's a guess you
know cuz I there's some that I look up
and they estimating their show off there
it's always usually 2 tomorrow from the
friends I haven't seen it it's usually
lower than what they really mean of
course yeah cuz they don't really know
what you're really know what you're
doing based on if you publicly tell that
correct Jeff Bezos Oh Jeff Bezos you
know his wife bout to go sizzler I know
I'm gonna slide into her do
- what's up girl what's up what's up
what's up what's up you want to go hang
out instead of dudes in podcasting and
big dick wait did he really lose the is
that over there oh no but they're gonna
they're gonna 72 million they're gonna
separate 70 billion billion there you go
give me the second richest woman the
person in the world of the ax divorce
he's the first richest woman in the
world and here's the [ __ ] up fight is
not what they said don't even no one's
even close right will shooting shooting
the second richest woman no no I said
first richest woman in the world all for
sure yeah no I think that was a fact
that she was yeah
just that's [ __ ] dick here's the thing
too though was he doing he was sending
nudies to his maid no no no no no - uh
mistress chick no choose our TV Lauren
Sanchez pretty hot has a crooked eye
which whatever some people have a
crooked eye is that a big deal I can
[ __ ] with it Jesus dude but I guess he
sent her dick pics oh he did did they
leak yeah some ass it bums me out like
who gives a girl yeah how long was the
affair going on yeah it's cool her lips
are real going I'm his gone for a while
and both of their partners knew about it
too so it wasn't like they were cheating
on his show really yeah oh why is this a
thing I don't understand if their
partners were comfortable with it I mean
just the fact that he set dick pics like
he should know better than to send dick
pics yeah I don't put your penis on the
Internet
anyone could access or it's easy not
remorse we all make mistakes
yeah but if you're that rich you don't
send dick pic really if I'm that rich
I'm posting my dick on Instagram going
okay I'm worth seven billion do you have
a nice dick pretty might have a terrible
penis as my point like you know your
aunt he looks like a penis right there
yes his dick right you know what his
eyes aren't great either ones larger
than the other he looks like a sniper he
does who say you sniper for a lot of
years he looks like he's getting out of
winking he looks like you've just been
shooting people and the one I still good
what if we find out that's a robot
malfunction that he's actually just it
says he was short stream here's what I
think if I'm [ __ ] Jeff Bezos I'm
going all really you know you leaked my
dick pics
hey it's
peep this huge [ __ ] pic right and then
they go what we're gonna take this down
go aria
I'm gonna buy the company I'm gonna shut
everybody down what if you're only
allowed to post if you open Amazon the
homepage it was just his [ __ ] you that's
all you could buy was a picture of his
[ __ ] and he could do that or he owns
Whole Foods - hey guess what's right
anyone that wants to buy food from Whole
Foods
you got to post a picture of dick on
Instagram I just made it legal to post
dicks cuz I own it zoomy like that that
juice is a $15 also we'd like to open up
your Instagram right now please and post
a picture of our boss's penis buddy
policy he has the power to do that y'all
so someone's wash team posted you know
that does he G yes he does this guy and
he hates Trump so there's always like
the anti Trump stuff I watched him post
all time
it's him it's his narrative I think
hating Trump now is also so like
repetitive that I'm like I just want to
be a fun to listen to like Kanye the
reason it's fun cuz you're like this is
crazy it's crazy crazy I want to hear it
I want to hear how what he loves about
him I want him so bad to go on [ __ ]
Rogen so I can hear him tell Rogen why
he loves him so much because no one's
giving him a real chance he just does
these short videos where he's like he's
like make he's making the country great
I want him to make it great I want to go
I want I want I want thriving I want
this this this but it's never it's like
soundbites it's never like you know the
same yeah well let him sit and let's
hear I wanna fall he doesn't have a plan
though but so maybe he does and I love
Kanye and I was on Rogen this morning I
asked I said you you really think
Cunnings coming on like he misses so
many interviews makes all these promises
and Rogen's like I talked to him on the
phone yeah he told me that - yo mommy
say hey we were on the phone around
funny Sarah you talked him for a while
he was like it was really like great
dude on the phone he's like he was very
conversational yeah it wasn't like it
wasn't like how some celebrities are
like aloof no some celebrities are like
so out of it that look yeah yeah yeah
they're not really paying attention I
told Rosie don't care if you like it
Kanye's track record what he's gonna do
is he's gonna wait til for his album to
come out you see some controversial [ __ ]
he's a marketing wizard yeah and then
it's gonna blow his album up yeah even
if it's super controversial he does on
purpose he really goes all the way and
he said slavery was a choice I remember
watching that and being like ah that is
that Wow yeah would you get one of you
just think today's like what's the worst
thing I could say slavery slavery was a
choice is pretty that's pretty high
there on the one of the worst things
that you could publicly I did it I know
and then he kind of did he kind of went
bat he kind of like got [ __ ] for and
then kind of backed out but then also
was like was also my sales or number one
he was like yeah but you know I believe
hopes number that how where did society
like with our Kelly stuff you know his
album sable sales went up after of
course the [ __ ] [ __ ] because
people went like this what happened are
Kelly was oh my god HUD music you know
what song is I loved that's what they
did yeah and then they click on and they
download a none Spotify I remember the
song if I could turn turn back the hands
a time do you remember that song uh oh
my it's like a 13-minute song on an old
man thing in it that's not our Kelly I
don't know this one wait seven minutes
yeah no I start dude it takes forever so
go to the middle
what's his best song obviously I believe
I can fly
no remix to ignition huh bounce bounce
bounce bounce kitchen I forget the room
that was a [ __ ] spring ranked anthem
that was me and everybody dead dude
that's bad at some point in the middle
of that song you were like do this guy
pissed on girls and people like yeah and
you're like is so good Gary DeLeo when
she was like [ __ ] 14 yeah she was so
gross play a little bit let's see what
yes some never released these long-ass
videos here this is perfect cuz it's the
chorus mm-hmm I've seen the rain in a
nightie what the [ __ ] what's happening
he's going back yeah it's all coming
backwards but I thought this is where he
was gonna sing again
we'll go back a little bit that
restaurant got to be that she walked by
they put that in the video it's so weird
the real restaurant imma [ __ ] sing no
candy hell yeah dude go piss on you
don't put him around kids but he can
think he's [ __ ] gross all for all
that [ __ ] dude you're [ __ ]
like songs jingle back hmm like it like
like I have a lot of I have a lot of
like um wait I have a lot of like
resiliency on like people's mistakes in
their life cuz everybody makes bad
mistakes but but not when not when
you're peeing on underage girls I guess
it's like nap no not and I'm not
defending any facet I wanna make that
very clear on the record the only thing
round kinda like oh god the parents
where'd the [ __ ] or the pit I know but I
guess you will do the same thing about
Michael Jackson with the kids it's like
do these parents are thinking think
they're the first of all they're
infatuated with this Fame which is
disgusting I agree but they're also
thinking this guy isn't gonna [ __ ] my
son no kids no different Michael Jackson
different has Neverland Ranch it's
Disneyland it's Michael Jackson GC just
really good with kids let's put them in
his Disneyland cool see but we know they
shave them off these girls are 15
they're not Alana or Kelly our shot date
with no not Shantae what's her name Leah
Leah's parents are like F cool hang out
with him oh oh you're just gonna hang
out with him all the time but I'm only
gonna stay the night I have a kid hold
it
no no grown man you're not no I'm here
all these parents were infatuated with
his fame and they thought so they got to
take some responsible enough to make
that a sin which is insane I know Julie
I agree but also what about the the
current females who are there now who
are like 21 22 and they're like yeah
he's taken our daughters prisoner they
can't get out I will tell you this right
now there's not any amount of security
our Kelly could hire that could keep me
out a few thousand if your daughter yeah
sure yeah so why don't you call the cops
do something why you just and I'm
telling you there's something something
going on here yeah of course there's a
whole system to keep well that dude
there was a system that kept him
employed how many artists that talk [ __ ]
about him now made songs with them I
mean somebody can either pull them down
like a hole what's the name Mike Rosen
Rosenberg Rosenhaus no no is I think
it's Rosenberg that does 97 yeah right
honey yeah Rosenberg he listed off all
the names last week he's like 'i wonder
how many [ __ ] are hypocritical
as [ __ ] he them named up every person
that's worked with him he was her
everyone the pissed thing came out
the underage [ __ ] after all these things
came out all these big artists still
work for them huge names yo jay-z was on
that like this jay-z's on that list yeah
that's just if this was uh now because
it's people don't have white girls y'all
long would he have been able to get away
with this you know I'm saying like if it
could yeah I feel like our society
because it is black on black they're
like god that's [ __ ] crazy man and
they're gonna do me some shade you
you're saying you're saying America's
America's like senses are heightened
when it company like a white girls in
danger yeah I mean that happens in the
news all the time I was reading this
thing there was people were like how
come you only hear when like a white
girl goes missing but like other girls
go missing but they're like all the time
it's cute white girl from Costa Mesa is
gone yep but they're like these couple
of Korean kids are gone but whatever
anyway this white girl from Costa Mesa
bleah it's so funny that they do that
they do they there was like by the way
it's if the girl if the kids are missing
on TV I guarantee you that their parents
are good-looking or they're cute it's
always like a cute kid that they put on
the news tons of kids go missing tons of
[ __ ] up [ __ ] happens but if they're
like kind of cute kids they're like look
at this sad poor sweet girl and you're
like this is because she's kind of cute
they throw kids on it's strange it's
[ __ ] weird dude here's jams god damn
yet some hits first of all ignitions his
biggest one how many how many how many
views 182 million and then I believe I
can fly on a scope of everything 182
million is not a lot for YouTube I'm
surprised that's nine years ago when he
did it I know it since then how that had
more and more thoughts he's old as
[ __ ] pisses on girls but if he came
out now with that hit you're talking you
know like huge basically the Drake back
then right so Drake has billions who's
the highest watch music videos billions
right Billy diva right no no no no not
even its that crane dude I'm pretty sure
sigh oh you know I party that guy that's
party with that guy wars ago before that
hit came out God done them stop before
guy named stuff was the thing I party
with him dude you like wow sorting out
of my life I'll show you on my Instagram
it's actually if you go through my
Instagram feed not you won't be able to
get seven years ago it's a very
beginning of my Instagram P there's a
picture of me and him in there no one
when I knew his manager he was a friend
age dude I knew his manager he was a
friend and he was like this great artist
named psy is coming here from Korea he
is a kpop star
this is one
Americans didn't know what kpop was by
the way no okay same but he was like
we're gonna take him out to this bar and
we went to this bar and there were some
low-key like famous people there that
like ha like like Topher Grace I was
like ha ha how how am i with the guy
from that 70 it was so many weird
celebrities that were like around this
this thing I didn't know how it happened
and then he asked um one of the
bartender's to go get him a bucket like
a clean bucket and he listed off all
these liquors and he was like in Korea
there's this thing that him and his
friends do where you dip a cup into this
bucket and then you drink from the
bucket it's like a it's like it's almost
like a Long Island iced tea of alcohol
it's like it's like a fruit punch like
yeah but it's a tradition that I guess
he does that him and his friends do or
whatever and I did it and it was [ __ ]
fun and he was cool as [ __ ] a big
English huh or did you know Gangnam stop
he didn't say anything
yeah he pointed a lot he'd go like this
and there and then I knew what that
meant
shyness shoes with my tongue yep
now he spoke English his English was
broken but I was naive use does that
video have that also that was kind of
old to like I feel like Drake or
Bieber's beating them now
no dude 3.2 billion now Gangnam stop oh
I know what beats it baby shark doo doo
doo doo doo doo mama shark/doo doo doo
doo de vie shark grandpa shark go away
I'm a shark top 5 most videos I know
just go to do just type in baby shark
for [ __ ] my food yeah man you're the
most food you can do it on the search on
the search engine there right can't you
write that isn't there a sort by I'm
doing here filter go to just Google then
google it dear young you count yeah baby
shark 5.8 billion des Pacita oh ok so
but it's not the Bieber one it's the
daddy yankee one but that's with Bieber
no not that one that no that Louise
forgot that one bro that's the original
gun on that one now that's what beer in
it bro Jan Dismas you know this is that
one first
this isn't Bieber original song either
do it was good this is the original dog
no Bieber in this are you sure click
through
just click through the middle of it
there's no Bieber in this I promise oh
that girl in this video no Beiber dog
rushed just Mike right now for her like
a Venice looks different yeah no vibra
here
yep no babes dude this is the og the
real version see do how about 3.7
million dislikes what is that what it is
yeah but 31 million likes yeah makes up
what's the world but for you guys
pill thing and I'm on the beach with my
buds there's a girl she's over there
with a bunch of kids those aren't even
her kids who lit this trashcan on fire
was it you laughing with kids hold on
we're on a closed street old guys
playing chess I'm still by the ocean is
this your boom box - this is nice yeah I
know most I can speak I'm fluent oh wow
I wish I was fluent yeah that girls
paint shaving this guy's head dude isn't
it kind of weird that age what they
choose musical why do they choose a shot
oh you're getting a haircut in a music
video
it's very strange it's guy looks like
kind of looks like you're havin a little
bit type-in baby baby shark am I gonna
hate that so much baby shark did you
watch the Gillette ad by the way you
want to talk about current [ __ ] event
it type in a baby shark how many views
2.1 billion who not that many please
don't play that I don't play it [ __ ] my
kids obsessed with this this started in
Korea - is it
Asians are so good at kid things why is
that why is it like what like why aren't
like young cute toy things hell's
children they know how to popularize
cute little tiny things maybe Americans
don't care enough about their children
[Music]
you know it's you know what's so [ __ ]
annoying this is gonna be my goddamn so
popular look at him
this shit's everywhere bro you're seeing
a child of the Orton to it this is
childish see Jim Jordans seeing it with
like real celebrities no please don't do
that dude it would please say it's gonna
save your day James Corden right James
Corden please y'all baby shark James
Corden oh he has legit people singing
with him though it's pretty funny and he
can he's a performer he can actually
sing his ass up well the fans be able to
see this janitor
I got a chop it up a lot that's so funny
chin I gotta chop it up a lot I have
he's like I have so much [ __ ] working
on this thing you have no idea you might
have to fast-forward a little you play
through my son it's like catnip bro I
can't like how good is he man I mean
he's very talented this dude I said
before he doesn't show a chief after
luncheon till he starts seeing he's
still doing this car karaoke but you got
paid for it now right it's not free
anymore what's good for him make money
dough to your show ever
yeah it is it's huge bigger than any TV
show where that segment is bigger than
his show correct
yeah like online YouTube there's like 50
million visa a human all right I can't
see James Corden Singham baby sharking
right that's only gonna [ __ ] riddle my
brain yeah his show yeah I did when we
did first first the Showtime show he was
very nice he's a very nice guy very cool
guy that the show is hard to do cuz you
sit on a couch together with other
people he's a little weird well it was
me Jim Carrey now magical so that was
grace not mad about that no it was
awesome because it was my friend and Jim
my boss but it was like it was kind of
weird like going down the line is a
weird format for a talk show but I don't
know whatever man to each his own
if I had a talk show everybody would be
everybody would be swimming I wanted the
whole show everyone swimming except for
me
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's a 13 down -
yeah that's my today - tread water the
entire it's called tread it's called
treading with Santino and they literally
have to tread water the entire time
also I just fed them oh wow yeah so
they're so heavy and see I gave him like
I give Mart idea of a pot roast yeah
like a beef pot roast what else you guys
get what's in the canoes you want too
much whew whew how we going for a hot
second I know daddy's gotta go I gotta
go in bed by 4:00
that's in 15 minutes yeah give us two
more all right this is jumped or I can
last a little bit longer because I like
you some [ __ ] much appreciate a
[ __ ] love you skills two more the
hoop shooting hoop game tonight and go
to the basketball game again I know dude
is that crazy last night was like the
back some [ __ ] I know I went with my
manager last night to the Laker game cuz
it was the Bulls so I had to go watch
the Bulls get their [ __ ] [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
they suck so [ __ ] watch dude it's
insane Lakers don't have LeBron God well
the Lakers [ __ ] blew dick - they're
not even fun to watch either I mean all
those LeBrons playing they're fun sure
but like my lawns I'll play dude he gets
all the [ __ ] hype i don't i think
oozmas the [ __ ] i love one who's not so
good I'll trade him right now for a
veteran well they're the Davis would be
that would be the swap crews when
somebody else yeah but I think the Bulls
suck dick right now because they have
talented dudes like Mark and Lori's
really good a [ __ ] yes thanks dawg
were you mad about your Chicago Bears no
man I was stoked
you [ __ ] jag off dude yeah [ __ ]
was I was though I was so sure how about
the kicker bad happens and like going on
talk shows and [ __ ] talking about it
people are so upset kicking shouldn't be
a part of football I've said it once
I'll say it again
I don't like [ __ ] kicking in football
it's [ __ ] it's [ __ ]
here's what should have only one kicker
I give you my rules real fast can I give
you my rules after every touchdown you
can either try for a pass which is two
points or a run which is one one point
that's what you should do and instead of
kicking off you start with the ball
start at the 30 30
faster game more points yes dude yes
dude and I'm concussions yes and if that
way that way it turnover on downs will
probably most likely beat near the half
near the half near the half anyone still
down for a punter see what I did
you still down for punts oh no no dog
I'm saying you all little brought downs
is a turnover on downs and then they
start on their 30 no they start where
you left them off a turnover on downs
Wow
the only reason a ball gets put in the
red zone is because of punting right
eliminate that and everyone's starting
pretty much in between 1:30 and the
other 30 to be a lot of scoring which is
what people love or better defense yeah
and you don't need this kicking [ __ ]
these kickers are [ __ ] there first of
all they're soccer players they don't
belong in the sport go [ __ ] play
soccer oh I'm not good enough to play
soccer so I play football get the [ __ ]
out of here I'm with you I don't want
that [ __ ] no more dude it's to go do
rugby stuff we don't do that [ __ ]
[ __ ] rugby [ __ ] dude I don't like
that kicking and rugby either why don't
they do that that is strange but
something jacked off do big jacked up
[ __ ] do jacked off you should check
what you dude they they you know they
get off dude you get more points if you
run with the ball and you jack off when
you're right man when you get a try if
you come right as you cross the try line
they 7ps 70 points what's the next news
thing that I'll interrupt and since you
got to talking about football not that
one this one that oh I know the Trump
fast-food thing yeah yeah which I paid
that's the funniest part God do you know
bother me the most about it I paid for
more people's meals during my [ __ ]
with first time I get high it's a big
special here's our bothered me the most
about it these kids eat fast food all
the [ __ ] time they're college kids
get a [ __ ] White House chef to cook
them the most gangster [ __ ] meal ROM
bro governments closed yeah he could get
some [ __ ] to go cook
dude he could get you Pacey all [ __ ]
knife Fieri or if del Frisco's who would
cook in a heart of college kids they
don't eat that good of meals but this is
what they eat all the time this isn't
training tables foots I've been there
Division one college to training food
that they give you
it's shit's [ __ ] it's like
chicken-fried steak just happy jobs he
didn't fly in Japanese like why goo beef
that's what he should have you want to
be a gangster
fly in some foreign [ __ ] for these kids
to have a treat these guys all eat [ __ ]
all the time they eat pasta and stay
that they get fries [ __ ] [ __ ]
attitude and here's the thing he goes
with no one complain they liked it well
first of all they're all 1920-21 in the
White House there are three
[ __ ] now they're doing press and ask so
they don't know any different a lot of
them oh yeah
yeah they said the whole thing is that
your own crab puffs that give me that
what's that other [ __ ] article that I
want to see that it's a football head
the kid with the football he'll be
appalled yeah what he football head what
he did say wants to go gay for a month
and people are furious he was joking
around on his podcast there you know so
it's New Year's Eve I like how we joke
rhyme all the time has [ __ ] about going
vegan for a month or you're talking
about resolutions not November he goes
on this month um would go gay for the
month no I'll mail March or something
like that he's just making a stupid joke
yeah [ __ ] sake and then everyone hears
I'm so upset man they're saying he's
being insensitive to the gay community
including quad well you just turn it on
and off snot how it works
they went over really hardcore he's
can't see a pause that's not how it
works
that's how come how come there's a bunch
of gay guys I know personal friends of
mine that say they're gonna flip
straight boys you know what that's a
real [ __ ] thing that I know that they
like to do yeah they love that [ __ ]
those guys that got flipped they weren't
straight in the first place I understand
but some people may be able to turn it
on and off glad you want to be such an
accepting why because called bisexual
yeah that's problem that you can't
they're saying you can't turn it on and
off who says maybe this guy wants a suck
a dick for a month then maybe the next
month he doesn't wanna suck dick anymore
who killed you always began he's not
saying that it's a right this is my bar
pit once way he's just saying man this
month I want start so silly it's so
dices what happens by the way when the
far far left shoot themselves in the
foot this is what happens
glad you can't just turn it on and off
that's not how it works how do you know
what he likes you guys are supposed to
promote the equal treatment and rights
of people who who are who are gay maybe
he wants to be get why how do you know
he's not gay but also who do you a joke
my you saying you it's not how it works
you can't turn on and off he's like woo
maybe for you or for your people but for
me I can turn on this month and suck
dick
how's that wrong right and why were you
guys just who called me out and send the
[ __ ] baby he sucks a dick once in a
while dude what is he the word that's so
funny I grew and accepted what did he
say back to them he put sorry very poor
choice of words my fault
let's it get together and talk about on
my podcast next week
tío just as a CEO just talked about
transgenders for a long time obviously
everyone on this audience knows none of
us are against trans people none of us
are like talking [ __ ] about trans people
we were making jokes in these worlds
he's making jokes saying maybe I'll go
gay for a month it's such a
light-hearted throwaway thing if he said
I hate gay people I don't think they
should be allowed to walk the streets
yeah glad go after him agree but come on
dude he that's not even offensive to say
mmm I'll go people do know November I'll
go gay for a month it's just he's making
a dumb joke correct stupid funny yeah
here's where also this is one of the
reason glad does it cuz now everyone's
talk about glad so it's them trying to
just jump on by the way by the way just
like we talked about that [ __ ] love
our last time the reason that all these
people let go after like the reason that
all these people are now coming back up
to go after things like the louis c.k
like new people emerging is because they
want their name in the head erect they
want their name in the [ __ ] article
it's not about them being a social
justice warrior as much as about being
like hey how many clicks that i get how
many [ __ ] likes that I get on my to
eat where I where I've said some dumb
[ __ ] that's like it's just so that's so
stats clickbait and chewing on that one
give me one more fun let's do a fun fun
one yeah those are gonna be hard to come
by
yeah cuz everything is sad the news is a
new super sad there's like one that's
kind of dude this microphone smells like
denture cream does Brian is like
Invisalign and [ __ ] you have never
psoriasis has his dentures ever fallen
out ah no this metals like dentures
this smells like mothballs its yeah it's
my it's the kids like it smells like a
64 Cadillac it's not you know what
smells like it smells like orthopedics
run like skate city yeah it smells like
junk play lives like sobs jobs would you
got price smells like that blue [ __ ]
[ __ ] that you like Clarence Carter's
ass alright here's the last one man yes
a gangster I posted this this is what I
mean about hot [ __ ] rot
Ali Wong's pants off recreation wait
what Ali Wong the comedian yes she
created it oh I thought it was gonna
what's this girl's name Caitlyn oh ha
have you seen you've seen it I'm sorry I
don't want to [ __ ] I'm not throwing
Ali
for this but can we just see the
original G that's it right here I love
Ali I didn't want to see this one have
you seen it yes cuz it's all good oh
dude I'm so turned on by her first of
all you know what the most dope thing
about this her all her all her teammates
and fans are like kickin it with her and
doing the same movements as her I think
it's so fun this jumped to splits is
crazy coming up she bounces up in the
air and then does the splits how cute is
she - how old is she she could choke you
the [ __ ] look at her legs would choke
you the [ __ ] out how strong her legs are
God rampage right here look look boom
what's up and that little boogie oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] Wow
right what pop it pop it dude see this
would make me go make me turn into like
a gay gymnastics dude for a month maybe
I'll be a cute little gymnast boy nah
maybe I'll just be a male cheerleader
for her I'll just show up to a event
creepy yeah she's [ __ ] dope Yeah
right to jump in the air and land on
your crotch can you do the splits Kat
yeah
does it hurt when you slam on the ground
like that it's gotta hurt a little bit
well if you if you stretch you should be
fine wow that's interesting because we
can't do that at all some guys can
though can't they yeah and I don't know
if their dude know Jesus Christ oh no I
feel like her ass helps her when she
lands like that dude that still got to
be painful all right it's also a bouncy
floor I know but still alright that's
good I don't I don't need to see Ali do
it I just wanted to see her I didn't see
it was online I saw people passing
around I just don't want the attention
taken off this dope girl
oh I'm not hating on Ali I just think
like but I love Ali that sacher's gotten
millions of retweets I think Ali buy it
going viral and say people do what I say
Ali's like let's see what Ali do yeah
let's see what she did
I'm not hating on her I just think that
girl's so dope I agree she's got her
husband kicking oh that's hilarious
with the baby cage that's the streets
died during tribute my favorite parts
house she's fixing her glasses Ellie's
hilarious what is she doing my tribute
to Caitlin Ohashi Ohashi is that it yeah
I have such bad eyes so hoshi japanese
Analia ones Japanese Chinese Wang oh
yeah you're right
we should go through a list of agent
last names and see if phrenic and gasps
oh yeah that would be fun I'm super
racist are you getting them all wrong
yeah I'd be gonna be hilarious what did
we what me what le with me we should
play what lack why or racist black white
a racist what's lead you know the last
name Lee what is that me that's uh
oh that's Bruce Lee that'd be Korean am
i right how many more can we do how
about win spelled Oh Wyn n no so I got
no spell spelled spelled Ngyuen and yes
that's Korean dad Gwyn that Gwyn dagwon
that Gleaves a linebacker plant thanks
to him for the Dallas Cowboys he's
Korean
oh that grim that's the easy way to very
doc win millions like the easiest wait a
minute there's only one group of people
with the last name it's been amines
I don't know that kind how about how
about how about how about um Park ah
let's Japanese Oh
is this real I don't know will you
isolate that clip and send that to me I
don't know my digits I want that so bad
for my house just to play it on my
living room
dude I don't know my Asia it's tough to
do with League win it's really nice it's
actually not that tough but I mean you
know what give me give me one more let
me redeem myself
what's one I'm trying to think one
that's not so easy cuz I because I think
you'd get I don't like those are tough
no those are the easiest mark those are
by far the easiest ones how about um
what's a good one how about uh Chang I
was gonna say that same one Chang how
about Chang that's so Chinese right it's
an interesting one is that not Chinese
it can be both actually so it's attacker
you thinking no Chinese Chinese chain
can be Chinese it is alright and what
else guys Chang Chang can be Chinese or
Korean or Japanese I feel like you had
it no it's Korean yes Japanese is very
like oh my gosh you so much fun thank
you for letting me take over the job
that it was intended from that I was
intended for you know it feels right it
does this chair is a little too boyish
for me like he's I know his little boy
body fits in here but like no it's
they're too big for that I'm too big I
do I will tell you it does hug the sides
really nice I just feel like there's a
lot of Kalymnos left over in here as
soon as should you spray this down
before I came in yeah we did as soon as
Kalin
any signs of decline in health you be
ready to go be ready to go now this is
basically I've been you're on deck
dropping a little something something in
his food every single day you're on
death good good cuz I want to be in the
on deck circle we should go over in her
a steel let's do it you're the Rookie of
the Year bro I love you baby thank you
ladies and gentlemen us the slugger the
red Ferraris out this is the fire in the
fry route